un parking désespérément vide les
clients de ce restaurant routier sont
aux abonnés absents poids lourds et
chauffeurs ont déserté les lieux à cause
de travaux en amont et des déviations
mises en place
ce jour-là à l'aise sera le seul routier
à venir déjeuner ici on vient manger ici
mais on en oublie trois montées ont fait
une vingtaine de kilomètres en plus que
le détour qu'on nous fait ça nous fait
des erreurs en plus et au niveau des
heures on n'arrive plus à passer
moi je viens de lyon et or niveaux
différents de rigueur à ses crocs oui
c'est sûr qu'il devra une sacrée perte
de chiffre d'affaires depuis un mois et
demi le pont de pause sur yonne est en
travaux et les poids lourds n'ont plus
le droit de l'emprunter ils sont donc
obligés de prendre déviation et ne passe
plus du tout par certaines communes
conséquences pour ce restaurant
il est vide ou presque à chaque service
les routiers représentent 90 % de la
clientèle
trois salariés travaillent ici et maryse
en est la patronne depuis 26 ans mais
les travaux ont duré un an et son
commerce pourrait ne pas survivre
maintenant c'est énorme comptez bien les
les loyers les charges l'électricité le
gaz là maintenant c'est l'hiver et le
chauffage et les faut payer tout ça
dans la salle quelques habitués reste
fidèle au restaurant et viennent
désormais aussi par solidarité
ça a été clair quasiment devenir du jour
au lendemain depuis depuis le déclic et
travaux ont commencé quoi la salle s'est
vidée ou deux tiers quoi friser moi
c'est mon point de chute jeu permet de
manger de prendre une douche comme tous
les chauffeurs comme tous les routiers
voilà on n'a plus personne sur le
parking
moi j'y reste voilà d'autres commerces
du nord de l'yonne souffre du chantier
en cours à ce jour le conseil
départemental a de son côté prévu aucune
indemnité